this digitize universal logo does not
really make sense for a Pacific Rim
sequel I mean first of all movie
specific unique logos are typically
reserved for surefire hits not sequels
most everyone expects nothing from
second of all it's a movie about giant
robots fighting giant monsters it's not
the matrix
why are you digitizing like when Rekha
tromping into the internet for this
adventure third of all digitized comcast
also the grand total of logos is 42
seconds and that offends me my
generation we were born into warp Jagr
Asian giant monsters attacked our world
previously on Pacific Rim they came
through the breach a gateway to another
dimension
damn this first 30 seconds a dialogue is
so exposition and footage heavy that I'm
now convinced the original movie could
have been much shorter most of the
world's recovered but few coastal cities
never did and the world is still picking
up the pieces I honestly think this was
written by a middle schooler go back
over there and see if those statements
make any sense when taken together most
of the world is recovered but a few
coastal cities never did and the world
is still picking up the pieces what some
of us live better in a broken world and
squattin wait but if the coastal towns
have been essentially abandoned how does
Jake keep this house fully powered and
operational there's no infrastructure
and the power grid has to be toast
not to mention look how clean that pool
is even after a wild party in the relief
zones you have to get creative
did he just trade an Oscar for some
cereal I mean that's neat I guess but it
doesn't tell me anything about this
economy at all except that gold or
cereal or both is greatly missed value
penny of nut Casey's out here trying to
slaps giver their own Yeager's you might
call them Jagermeister somebody please
kill this guy for me villainous
character asked one of his henchmen to
kill protagonists instead of easily
doing it himself cliche well good Jake
somehow knew exactly when those cargo
doors were closing and that they would
be bulletproof I guess we've established
that this mother Superman so can we just
get to the egg ring already I have
actually removed a thousand sins at this
work this could literally be a shot from
one of the Transformer sequels and you'd
never know the difference
meanwhile 12 hours later after nothing
happened that you might want to see hey
this expositional wall of news clippings
doubles as a premature celebration
cliche G comes around this corner and is
so obsessed with the overhead cables he
doesn't see the Yeager robot until after
a few seconds I'm calling bull if he
wanted to whammy reveal the viewer and
so they did it to the protagonist as
well even though that ultimately makes
no sense oh they get Paramount too
off on a bumblebee cameo for this thing
wait this is a Mara's primary home
security system she's got a goddamn
Jaeger sitting in her workshop but
leaves her windows unlocked and leaves
the path to the workshop unblocked and
doesn't even have a gun or something if
someone walks in and on the first try
under duress from an impending security
breach luck
this asshole starts running for cover
even though scrapper hasn't broken out
no we're really made a sound at this
point stop just a reminder this is
Mara's first fucking time using this
Jaeger and yet she's able to control it
perfectly jumping around on nimbly
bhimli from rock to rock unnecessary
slo-mo of Zack Snyder meets unnecessary
building destruction of Michael Bay sack
obey Mikey Snyder
so Michael snide Bey I have a dozen
jokes written about how this movie is
basically a combo ripoff of Transformers
Power Rangers and Godzilla and they're
all true and this moment is as good as
any to give the film 36 sins at once one
for each of the dozen jokes I left out
of the script times three each for the
movies this thing is clearly ripping off
hence 36 I showed my map haha G but
apparently it took Ajax like one second
considering he rebooted track scrapper
to its exact location and caught up to a
pretty significant distance so you
wasted that fucking backup battery for
one second this is your final warning
if the kaiju were defeated a decade ago
why the skyscrapers size Yeager's being
used as police in the present day
granted this girl is using a small
personal Jaeger bot and maybe typical
police can't bring that down but it's
being suggested this China mercy acre is
actively patrolling the street stopping
crime and that's wasteful as tomorrow
must a program scrapper to attend the
Prometheus school of running away from
Yeager's in the future not only are jail
cells couette they'll throw grown adults
in there with the adolescence I talk but
you bombed it they need to meet and
become friends right shut up Jake says
this to a child by the way even though
he broke into a Maura's house hijacked
her Jaeger and your power source
remind me why we're rooting for this guy
again Chang what I'm not training their
dumb kids geez can Jake be any more Han
Solo in this movie as this plane copter
lands I'll take this moment to point out
that everything about this movie feels
JV the cast other than John boyega the
effects the script the fucking sound
effects how do they want me for the
program
Putin pilots is your own Jaeger people
like that kind of stuff yeah but have
they sent everyone that built a knockoff
Jaeger to the training academy didn't
they just say they were fairly common
that haircut just call you
it depends did you just call that dude a
haircut you know you still hold the
record
what record shut up Jesus Christ this
dialogue can't make up its mind between
being overtly expositional and
offensively antagonistic so hoping
they're you back I mean it couldn't have
been the paid they used an ancient
persuasive technique known as
screenwriter you need all the showers
you can get man have a mosque you know I
like this movie better when it's gone
starship enters troopers aliens
Kingston's game we're gonna be trained
by penthouse so not like he was the one
who died help me close to breach this
girl's mean but she's right enough she'd
fit right in here at team cinemasins
won't jump together be a mechanic boy
one is for pilots Jesus lady in all
movies feel they need a bully secondary
antagonist but to pilots and mechanics
really beefed in this universe like the
Sharks and the Jets also you asked her
about her Jaeger and she was actually
talking about piloting it when you
interrupt him to be a jerk face what's
her problem
took her three shots to pass the
entrances yeah don't think she likes how
you landed here isn't Vic sitting very
nearby with an easier shot of this
conversation discount Kobayashi Maru I
thought we might have something here now
I'm not so sure I'm sure a lot of people
said this about Scot Eastwood's acting
ability well maybe she's not the only
one that doesn't belong here that's
racist also why are they here Jake's
hologram sister just randomly showed up
to the coastal jail he was sent to then
arranged a transport for him an Amara to
get into this highly selective training
program I mean does this plot me jack
except for the lead-up to the inevitable
Monster Mash show her new recruit how
it's done man not Chris Evans is a dick
this righteous raging Roy D Ranger
requires remedial wranger management
rehabilitation also does this movie
realize how divergent it feels and how
not a good thing that is oh yeah
everyone has that shelf in the fridge
that holds multiple cans of whipped
cream which is right in front of the
beer which is right in front of a slew
of lemons just hanging out in the back I
call it the whip beer and chill with a
drink
sure ice creams up top I know he's
British of some variety but goddamn dude
beer and ice cream do you hate your
taste buds you have to understand
so this movie now trying to slip in some
joke enos or is it the self-serious
substandard effects romp we've been
getting so far make up your mind dammit
Shou and her team are presenting this
new drone program they have could make
us all obsolete wait isn't this
something that Jake should not only know
about but should be thrilled about but
training is the only thing he's here for
and if they're obsolete that's it but
all he can muster is mild amusement what
the hell is with this movie she doesn't
do the whole handshaking thank dr.
Newton guys like Charlie days trying to
express the cool of 90s era Christian
Slater but has the role of a hyperactive
John Tudor character sure looks like
someone saw the pizza delivery guys act
and there's something about Mary and
made it into an actual person is that
kind to blood fYI kaiju blood is now
super fuel eat your heart out last Jedi
scenes at open table how much will we
also have on how your cut is whatever
dad
don't make me question your loyalty
understand between you his boss and that
other science guy how insecure are you
about your drones to go full ultimatum
no contact here after the mere mention
of rocket boosters on Jaeger and you
think a bunch of desk jockeys are better
than us well considering this movie's
going almost 30 minutes without anyone
yeah going except for Amara I'm inclined
to believe president business here I
don't trust the tack not yet at least
well it looks pretty good to me yeah I
saw a 45-second presentation that relied
solely on buzzwords and Holograms seems
to check out in case you confused it for
Sydney Bristow
I'd suggest it's insane to think that
future humans would worship oversized
hungry monsters but I've been paying
attention to world politics the last
couple years and it's hard to laugh
about also you know what I like in my
movies about interdimensional punching
geopolitical protests three two one drop
damn could you not drop the Jaeger a
little further away from the crowd I
know you're probably not gonna hit them
but that was a drop from a disturbingly
long distance and could have easily gone
wrong so I'd appreciate if you'd stop
thinking about Jules not gonna happen
Jules oh you mean that fully realized
female character that was featured in
all of 30 seconds of this movie
immediately attracting the main
character from her looks alone totally
know who that is
this is command advised that we have a
role bigger how the does something that
large and requiring of such specific
training to use even gets stolen or
built by terrorists without your knowing
oh good Jake caught that probably empty
helipad and saved a few assholes that
were pretty sure our assholes and also
who cares about those other people that
were likely in the building itself what
a hilariously specific thing for a
Jaeger to do that robot from the first
door movie is kicking Finn's ass Rock'em
Sock'em no BOTS
oh Jesus they have lightsaber swords now
me with a copy of a copy of a dildo in
the shape of an original movie yeah all
these people that seem to be surviving
right now in this shot they're all dead
I hope your personal ohmmeter got high
enough to make it worth this movie
killing more downtown humans than Man of
Steel do you mean punch him really hard
let's play multiple choice gravity sling
is a a space travelers sex apparatus be
a newfangled Rock projectile device see
an electro swing act out of Billings
Montana or D some technobabble a
screenwriter made up that only sort of
means something also absolutely positive
there are no humans in those cars
because I don't think they checked if
there were any humans in those cars
now you know how Kevin Dyson felt that's
a real shame
Mike oh we're in Suicide Squad she'd be
right as rain he's scared to the
incoming three acres and walks into the
bay and we cut away suggesting no one
followed him and the three acres just
landed 20 seconds later and collectively
decided water was bad and boring and
scary so they went for hot dog do I have
that right I have to make a good
connection I can't do that if you jump
in your gums really feels like 48
percent of this movie is Jake telling
tomorrow to shut up in various ways geez
Tamara's like 15 years old which means
this memory would be in 2025 or later
but you're telling me that Polaroid
knockoffs are still used well nobody
uses them in 2018 except dedicated
hipsters and Taylor Swift job casual
kaiju kill and want to know who was
piloting that rogue Jaeger but not
enough to do any investigating
immediately after the attack I like to
let those things marinate for a couple
days nobody else will miss you bye
sounds like soon a 20mm bushel 48 is how
the hell would Newton not know this it's
his job to get these drones to roll out
but I guess exposition mukhda manding
had to wait until just now to tell him
he's on severe deadline and does he know
this is happening since he's already got
kaiju syndrome cuz he looks pretty
surprised here so Newton has a secret
kaiju Luke Skywalker and a vertical tube
of water and that's a problem both in
movie and externally from a lazy
narrative point of view Jerry who are
they
it's the air Yeager naming committee
like the one with the National Weather
Service that names all the Hurricanes
and given the name obsidian fury how
dramatic are those assholes I'm not
gonna wash out I'm gonna be a pilot
they couldn't Telegraph this poor
bastards death more if they two had him
wear a red shirt because it's better
deema fake Wow discount shailene woodley
learned the proper russian insult and
basically a day or less I don't know
this movies playing fast and loose with
time and it seems way too soon for her
to new Russian insults that's my main
point mission to take gipsy Avenger to
see what the hell's out there why not
just reposition the satellites wait he
walked here he didn't even use the
drones to fly him most of the way here
and drop him off how much fuel did you
waste on there looks like Marcos message
was a dead end
you flew all the way up to Siberia
suited up the Jaeger walked a few feet
look at this landscape for 10 goddamn
seconds and you're immediately ready to
throw in the towel I know they want to
take this fury road out and on but Jake
and Nate just willingly throw themselves
into the Balrog pit with no regard for
gypsy Avenger they should all die from
this regardless right guys
yes we want to see these Jager fights in
all their glory but what's really
frustrating is trying to figure out what
things can and can't do and why they
have effective attacks but neglect to
use them like instead of punching the
dickhead at the beginning of the fight
why not use the very useful plasma
cannon that rogue Egger was piloted by a
Meatwad Bruce Almighty takes a break
from the nighttime and brings us a
ginormous Sun for a change never would
be good you guys can stay here
here in the studio green screen room of
non reality please don't make me stay
here it's so fake and green-screen II
what is it I don't know but if I've
learned anything from Fantastic Four and
alien movies by god I'm gonna grab it
with my bare hands and dismiss from the
program dude come on they all wandered
around a Jaeger body and spent all the
twenty seconds in there sure Amara's
partner got a little hurt but is that
really an expendable offense and only
amara and sigh you don't deserve this no
you don't deserve this scene movie as
you spent nowhere near enough time on
these barracks to earn this Rando
coconut actually caring about her right
now
tomorrow next Jaeger you build make it a
big one frenemies America said it I'd
like Charlie day to be Charlie day in
this scene but set to one hundred and
thirty nine percent oh yeah it looks
like these Jaeger drones are I Robot egg
all over the base listen I'm telling him
nothing matters in this movie so long as
we get the 360 circular hero shot of the
15 year old girl in a raincoat we get
that shot this thing sucks up money like
a veritable vacuum machine hot girl
saves hot guy from falling debris and I
have lost track of how many better
movies this thing is ripping off
[Music]
we'll be cuts from a catastrophic scene
to a shot of an elevator playing cheesy
music Alicia what did you just do what
I've been planning the last 10 years I'm
ending the world but why now and how was
brainwashed Newt
acting so much like regular new goddamn
I know this sets up a giant climactic
battle but this movie makes no sense man
these circle jerks are always awkward
there's got to be one guy that looks
over at you so a bunch of human control
drone bouncer going to laser blast the
ocean floor in order to reopen the
breach and let in more kind you all
because Charlie day was pissed that
fistfight didn't do better at the box
office close in the field are open in
multiple breaches across the pacific
rick roll Yeager's why did the
precursors taking over the jaegers cause
the growth of robot shoulder spikes 38%
of your company is fully automated it
really wasn't very hard to reallocate a
little over here
and a little over there isn't it a
little early for the villain to be
exposing his master plan
we've still got almost 35 minutes and 35
million of CGI to waste before we're
done with this show movie saves money by
inserting a few scenes from Tommy Lee
Jones volcano movie yeah Ben you
wouldn't know what they're up to you
have to find him first
but Shou ordered security to find noot
immediately after he left the room and
he was in the building
isn't that a secure building goddam this
movie could try and explain something
anything right here now Fuji Japan in
case she can be used it with Mount Fuji
Ohio the movie wisely speeds up
frequently throughout this scene about
the building of the world's most giant
and disingenuous Lego structure ever
oh hi Jules glad to see they came up
with something for you to do normal
handshake strong and steady
but how did Amara learn that the last
time we saw her attempt to drift she
sucked ass and watched her family die
again
so she's suddenly able to do it now just
because Jake speech got her fired up
wait the kind you have been on the move
for hours if not days at this point and
the PPD see know exactly where they're
going so why is there anyone left on the
streets of Tokyo man I'd hate to be
watching a quiet place in the adjacent
theater to this ball the city is secured
in underground shelters well except for
the several thousand people that
literally just experienced a brutal but
cinematic death on screen
sure they have ostensibly cleared the
city of people that do think about
unnecessary property damage Real
Estate's expensive in Tokyo huh I guess
this kaiju is wearing that black panther
energy transfer suit tech I don't know
how many are left in Tokyo at this point
like can you try anything other than an
architecture based attack okay we're
going with giant robots again
all right real original guys I can only
assume this was Guillermo del Toro's
reaction when the studio asked him to
direct the sequel listen I know we've
got to build bigger better courage you
for the heroes to eventually kill but
why would they wait to attack until
after it's been roided-up they've got
this race the Phoenix report but we're
still in the fight yeah and it sure is
nice for a mega kaiju to take so long to
attack again
okay maybe Amara has been listening to
the communications with the command
center and knows that Nate's hurt but if
that's the case why hasn't anyone been
communicating with each other since they
were attacked the movie is essentially
making us believe that emeritus knows
that she's got to get to the Gipsy which
is some kaiju science bull what are you
doing getting out of your way you got
this brother
yep I'm sure you'll be perfectly fine
with this child that's displayed limited
skills with large Eggers and would in no
way suggests using the other more
experienced pilots as a replacement for
me
Godspeed scrapper survives this holy
shout seriously welding directly next to
an incredibly unstable power source this
movie gives a big ol middle finger to
science
I'm sorry smarty what we got the world I
mean probably but there's really no
guarantee this plan will work right 20
kilometers to impact man the last third
of burne Gorman's performance in this
movie is comprised of dramatically
shouting directly at the camera usually
with a Dutch angle dude you're right in
there if make a kaiju doesn't sound his
barbaric yawp here movies over also the
world wait if Nate had enough strength
to survive the ejection locate Newt get
all the way up to the top of the shell
building and take his ass out you're
telling me he couldn't contribute to the
Jaeger at the end of the fight Bing Nate
you think you saved your crappy little
world we're gonna keep coming Charlie
Day dedicates his performance in the
last scene to Jesse Eisenberg's version
of Lex Luthor my generation we were born
into war looks like Marcos message was a
dead end uh phrasing and you think a
bunch of desk jockeys are better than us
oh so now you think you're better than
me before we get started does anyone
want to get out I do they do I feel like
[Music]
this is the end
a hundred percent that's the way that
it's done that's the way you do it money
for nothing you choose
[Music]